a lot of people think that well they
read the script they really liked it
that's
meaningless
it's like did they buy it
no
what do you say to screenwriters who say
it's not their job to get the movie made
it's simply their job to write the
script have an idea and get that out
there
well
when people tell me they want to write
a script
i say to them
do you want to write a script or do you
want to make a movie because they're two
very different things
and early in my career i was friends
with charles jaffe who was woody allen's
agent and then his producer and i said
charlie and film and tv where's the
power
he said in television it's the writer
producer hyphenate ideally the writer
executive producer hyphen at the
showrunner uh in films it's generally
the writer director hyphenate uh
sometimes a producer but often the
writer director and and that told me
where to go in my career i went into
television because writers run
television and so that meant that what i
wrote would get made what i wrote would
get on the screen
i'd say 90 95 of what i've written has
been shot
and my friends who are screenwriters
have lives of endlessly writing scripts
for these other people who
may or may not be uh unstable but most
of their work doesn't get made and that
i know screenwriters have worked for
decades and none of them they've earned
a good living and none of their work has
gotten shot for me that would be a
useless life because
my goal is to create a body of work that
moves an audience that entertains an
audience that is meaningful to them and
uh
so you have to know what what you're
trying to accomplish so if a
screenwriter wants to be a screenwriter
doesn't want to be a director doesn't
want to be a producer then yes they can
write scripts but those scripts may not
sell or if they sell they may not get
made the way you wanted them to get made
or you may get fired or they may be they
may sell and be and never get made so
if your goal is to make a living as a
writer there are a lot of different ways
to do that
or as an actor or as a director as a
producer but the more you say let's
chart a path
that
gets my work made and gets me an income
then that's a strategy
that allows you to be much more
effective
and and i'm not saying not to have a
career as a screenwriter i have friends
who've made millions and millions of
dollars uh as uh screenwriters and
they've had some great films made um but
you're a little more thrown
to the the wins of fate
in that direction so
so one thing i would say to anybody who
wants to be a screenwriter is
get get mentors who are successful
screenwriters
because you must know what the rules are
because they don't tell you what the
rules are generally and unless you know
what the rules are unless you know the
secret language you will endlessly be
frustrated and the secret language we
all learn it because
in order to be successful you have to
know what like when you're in a room
pitching
you have to be able to read the room and
it's very funny because i once elaine
and i once went in and pitched something
uh with someone who wasn't fair fairly
new to the business
and at the end of the meeting he came
out saying well um why didn't you say
this and this and this
and i said because we were saying it but
just not in words we knew
you know the person i was pitching to
knew that that was under everything we
were saying and you know and and you
also know what's a yes what to know you
know where you have enthusiasm where you
don't
there's there's a lot of ways to read
that stuff and and many of the
lessons many people are very frustrated
because they think they're succeeding
when they're not
because people in hollywood will act
like they're enthusiastic they'll love
your script they'll love your idea and
then suddenly they seem to blow a hot
and cold you know and it's because a lot
of people want to be liked but the
moment you're out of their sight they
forget about you and it's on to the next
thing and so you can never trust their
word
and
so again that's why you don't want to
a lot of people think that well they
read the script and they really liked it
that's
meaningless
it's like did they buy it no
but they want me to come in again and
pitch again okay well that's not bad but
again it's sort of like
they really liked it but they didn't buy
it or they you know they when you go on
on audition and they say well um that
was great but you know thanks but if
they bring you back yes then you are
making an impact we have to really look
at
what a cause and effect because there
are a lot of things that people feel are
symbolic victories that are actually
not moving them forward and a real
victory is when something gets sold when
something gets made once you know and
when they hire you to do the next one
you know it's you can build upon success
if you're consistently not succeeding
then you really have to look at what's
not working and find out why it's not
working but again you need to have
people who will tell you the truth but
be supportive no one has a right to say
to anybody you'll never make it no one
has the right to say to anybody you
don't have ability you're not you're not
good enough these are irrelevancies the
people who succeed in this business are
the ones who are incredibly persistent
my friend nicholas meyer who directed
wrath of khan he said the key to success
in hollywood is persistence with charm
because you need the persistence to get
where you're going and the charm means
that they won't get pissed off at you
but um
but again i know so many people who
think it's like well i've written 10
scripts and none of them have sold
well you might try something that you
know i mean again if like often people
come to my round table and they've made
like 10 shorts or 15 shorts i say to
them stop making shorts make a feature
because you can't you can't really make
a living doing shorts as far as i know
but if you take several shorts and link
them thematically
that can be put together into a feature
so you can do an ensemble film
made up of shorts if they're linked by a
character or a theme
or or any number of things or a location
and so start thinking that way because
if a feature is too big to do in one
gulp you might over a course of your be
able to make three or four shorts put
them together as a feature and
bang you're good to go and so
i i think
one really has to look at
where one's headed
and i think the keys to succeeding are
you have to
write from the heart
learn your craft so that means either
that doesn't mean go to go to college
necessarily in screenwriting but it does
mean read scripts see why they work see
what works and what doesn't be in
writer's groups where you get feedback
but it has to be supportive that doesn't
mean it's not critical but there's a lot
of toxicity you don't want
toxic notes because they don't help you
they just put scars on your heart you
know and uh
find mentors who do who who whose work
you love who have and who are authentic
because again as i've said before there
are two hollywoods there's a hollywood
of creepy horrible people
and then there's a hollywood of people
who are doing the work they love they
stand by their word they're good family
people and and they're good friends to
and they're authentic and that's the
hollywood you want to be part of that's
the hollywood you yourself want to
represent
you do not have to become a slime ball
to make it in hollywood that is there
are many many bad habits that people
have you do not have to a
become something you loathe and b i
strongly urge people to avoid working
with people they loathe you will not
just have one chance i mean if you're if
you
really put your heart and soul
and a work ethic into the into pursuing
this you'll find opportunities you'll
make opportunities um you don't have to
be the at the whim of someone crazy and
nor should you be and uh but you also
have to decide from the beginning if you
need to be rich
because if you need to be a millionaire
then yes the studios and the networks
are are the the road to take if you can
if you don't need to be rich well then
there's a million ways to earn money
writing books writing scripts you can
make films that that earn some money
earn some money back you can have your
own youtube channel that brings in money
from ad revenue you there's a lot of
ways to the patreon accounts i mean i
know people who are their art is being
supported by their patreon accounts and
uh
you know it's just
you you need to talk to people who are
succeeding in the way you want to
succeed and say you don't ask them for
help you don't say get me an agent or or
or open this door for me or or introduce
me to your friends no you ask advice
and and you say how did you do this or
what what when you when this happened
what did what what did you do and and
sometimes they'll give you answers that
you can apply and sometimes they'll give
you answers that you can't apply if you
can't apply it then keep asking the
question of different successful people
until you find the answer that you can
apply
and uh
and you know but there's there are many
different paths to success
and uh
and it's just
man you know rod sterling used to say i
when he when he would write scripts he
would say is this the truth as i know it
or better yet the truth is i feel it
and that's
words of wisdom
let's take another scenario and that is
someone's written what they think is an
amazing script it's been purchased and
too many hands got involved and quote
messed it up yes and that happens often
in fact i know some
writing team where they wrote a horror
script that they were very proud of
and it got went through all these
different writers and they were very
worried about that and finally the
writers guild decided they would have
solo writing credit but then when movie
came out it was really terrible because
of all the rewrites and they were blamed
because theirs was the only name on it
and so you know
that's where i say
if you're willing to take power
if you're willing to take responsibility
if you say i'm going to write and
produce and direct
that doesn't mean you do it alone
you're not a one-man band but it means
that
you make sure that what you intended it
to be is what it is you know because the
moment you sell a script
then
the moment you sell a script
you're at
you're no longer the boss the moment you
sell the script you're no longer you no
longer have power whoever bought it has
power
and so
it can be any number of things anything
can happen to it it's like putting moses
in the little reed basket and floating
him down the nile you know it's like bye
kid
i mean will you become you know moses or
will you become pharaoh or will you
become like you know joe who
shines the statues you know
there's you have no power over that
anymore because you floated him away
that's like what people do with scripts
um and so you know
when i was a writer on staff a writer
producer story editor
one of the things i would say at the
beginning of my job is i would say my
preference is that i not be rewritten by
others i will do as many drafts as it
takes but i prefer that my my work is
what gets to the audience
and because i was a hard worker and a
good writer
my bosses honored that it was very rare
that i would get rewritten and
so
you know it's uh
you know you you work harder
but
you um
have less sleepless nights
you know
so uh but again it's
it's so easy to shoot stuff now it's so
you know i mean everywhere i turn you
know i see people shooting short films
or what or features or whatever t web
series tv shows you know it's
science fiction never predicted that we
would all have video cameras in our
pockets
and there's so many benefits of that
and you know
fear can stop you laziness can stop you
you really have to say to yourself
if i have to work hard
it's worth it because i want
i want people to know what i'm doing i
want to share this with the world it has
to be that because otherwise if you're
going to be half-assed about something
then go work at mcdonald's you know
because if the fries are not the best
fries ever made then it's okay
but if you're going to make movies or tv
shows then then step up
there's only when you when you encounter
resistance or adversity you can either
step back
or you can step up that's it those are
the only two choices and if you step
back you'll never know what would have
happened if you would just really put
your shoulder to the wheel
so you know i my career has been made by
hand
and i'm very proud of that
you